Paul maloney asks you,
edited out a disagreement with Camille Paglia,
what was it?
No,
no,
that's not the case.
There was a piece edited out,
but it wasn't because there was a disagreement,
it was because there was some glitch in the video or something like that.
Generally speaking,
and you know,
I can't say this with absolute certainty,
but I do and so does my crew do everything we possibly can to leave the videos
alone except for getting rid of things that would be of no interest to anyone
that are mistakes.
So there was no disagreement.
Are you interested in coming to Australia?
Yes,
I've been invited a couple of times but it hasn't worked out yet.
But,
um,
my book will be published in Australia I think sometime in January as well.
And uh,
I imagined that all becoming there at some point in order to talk about my book
and so on.
Um,
okay.
Trace is,
how can a person go through the future authoring process of imagining a future
for yourself as though you or someone you care about when you barely don't care
about yourself or even hate yourself?
Yeah.
Well,
I would say that.
Okay,
go through the exercise anyways and act as like try to extend to yourself some
courtesy.
You know,
sometimes you have to act something out before you can start to believe it.
And so I would say sit down and
pretend that you're your friend,
you know,
trade the probability that there's something so wrong with you that you don't
deserve any regard whatsoever is zero,
you know?
So and I would say if,
if you just can't get it together,
you know,
maybe you are depressed and maybe you need to go talk to someone because you
don't have to be depressed.
You'd talk to a physician,
you know there are treatments for depression.
If you happen to be depressed and if you actually hate yourself,
then it's a possibility that that's what's going on.
I don't know how old you are,
but you know there are effective treatments for that sort of thing.
You might want to find out if there's actually something wrong physically or,
or psychophysiologic Lee,
you know,
because you don't have to trudge through life absolutely miserable there.
Antidepressants for example,
work really well for some people.
Not for everyone,
but for some people.